[Music]
thank you for being with us guys we do
appreciate it uh monday show we have a
very special guest uh mers can you set
up uh introduce them will i get
everything set up on my ass yes i'm very
happy to have this guy on i'm actually a
big fan um he's the host of predator
poachers a lot of people may know him as
uh gordon flowers he's also uh you might
have seen him in some of the videos with
alex stein cassidy campbell he's also uh
likes to go there and uh you know rile
those uh those town meetings up uh alex
rosen joining us man thanks for coming
on man how you doing how's it going guys
how's it going doing good man good to
see you again
good to see y'all too yeah yeah man i'm
very happy to have you on um i was very
excited to meet you when we were in
dallas because um
i brought you up just because me and
alex time we were hanging out with him
one night and like just organically
talking about
you know people we enjoy on the internet
and i brought you up completely like
without you know any kind of provocation
and he's like oh i know that guy he's
going to be here you want to meet him
and i'm like i definitely want to meet
this dude because i i love your stuff
man i love what you do
um
you've come a long way in what you do
and uh yeah so for those of you that you
i've played some of your stuff on um on
my other show too so a lot of my the
audience kind of knows who you are we
have a lot of overlap but
uh you go out
and uh you have decoys that work for you
and um you know you find legitimate
predators out there and then you go and
confront them and actually
do some real jedi mind [ __ ] on them and
get them on tape to confess to
everything and then you basically get
them locked up right
um that's how it works a lot of the
times i'd say we have an arrest in 27
states at this point and just a few days
ago we got our seventh conviction in our
seventh state um in georgia the other
day so
which which means that youtube youtube
probably hates you right i'm assuming
because everything you just said leads
me to believe youtube doesn't want you
around
yeah yeah it's just poking the bear even
more the better results we get i agree
yeah
that's just i mean that's how it goes
but i mean uh but we'll play one here
people can see this this one was a uh a
gentleman in utah correct oh yeah i
specifically picked this clip out
because um
it's it's very funny because he's he's
talking to this guy and this guy is
basically like very smug and starts
talking to alex about you know well you
know you only have like one semester of
college and i have a master's degree so
he starts like
basically talking down to him even
though he's the one that got caught
talking to what he thought was like an
11 year old girl on the internet
and then you kind of flipped it on him
because he kept saying in this before
this clip like well i wasn't going to
meet her in person it was just like over
the phone and stuff but he kept saying
like in the messages like i want to eat
your [ __ ] and all this [ __ ] so that's a
setup for this clip when you finally go
all right i'm going to just ask you like
a four-year-old idiot with no education
and this is one of my favorite clips
here we go
i hope this uh scares you out of doing
this again yeah yes yep
so you said
and again i'm going to ask you as
somebody with a second grade education
to mr master's degree
i wish yeah i mean pretty soon your
associates as soon as
allison finds out about this it's going
to turn from a masters to a bachelor
pretty quick but
by the way he always he's always got
killer lines man that was a good one
that was [ __ ] good man oh [ __ ]
sex um
yeah i digress i'm just i'm just kidding
buddy but um okay so
you said hang out
so he said
hang out
so
i'm going to ask you as a second grader
mr paulie what do you think are you
hanging on portion or is that over the
phone
okay
kiss make out
is kissing and making out over the phone
or he doesn't push him
[Laughter]
just making him answer like
this in person
oh my god and by the way we've met we've
we've met we've met we've met alex over
here he's a big boy
right yeah you played some ball right
some football
well
um i was on a college team not going to
say i play a big difference i was on the
roster but um i did not enter the field
no it was only my freshman year
dude you're a big boy man
what do you what do you you know yeah i
just watched one you uploaded the other
day that the guy is a sonic manager
and he's like four foot 11.
standing next to him and it's it
literally is the funniest
visual you've ever seen in your life
like
he yeah he'll tower over you man
dude this is yeah that was that was that
was a good one for sure he was actually
built like sonic the hedgehog hedgehog
he was this really short little mexican
guy in texas that was 411 and he's just
asking him questions and i'm like i
don't even know how you can hear you all
the way down there
okay
snuggle mr paulie he's snuggling and
pushing was that over the phone
okay
do some touching on each other mr paulie
is that over the phone one portion
i don't know it's brutal man what is it
it's so brutal but i uh i gotta say man
i i found your channel not long ago
probably like
two three months ago and i immediately
it immediately
became one of those ones where now it's
always in my [ __ ] suggestions because
i've watched like everyone like now it
suggests like other old backup channels
of just his stuff and there's obviously
there's some other people out there that
do some good work
um
but you know you seem to really find uh
sort of like uh
a way of making it good content and
being funny about it but like also
getting the work part done because i
have to say you compared to some of the
i've seen other channels where they
literally just show up and scream at
people and spit on them and like try to
fight them in gas stations and i'm like
oh of course you're turning them into a
victim of a crime now
you know what i mean right right yeah no
that's that's of course what a lot of
people call professional i mean you know
we got a lot of hate for being quote
unquote unprofessional but then they
cite like those channels as like oh you
got to be more like so and so they just
scream in their face it's it's hilarious
dude i mean and it's it's and by the way
now that now that your stuff's taken off
don't worry a bunch of people are going
to steal your stuff and i give you
credit get ready for that that's fun
that's a big part of it oh absolutely
it's happened with the city councils
already yep yep which by the way you
look of course your predator approach
stuff is great but your city council
stuff as a matter of fact i saw you at
the trans rally with stein this weekend
too that was uh it was very funny like
hearing you know what i mean like
hearing both of you guys doing it and
the way they bro the way they went after
because they all know him in dallas
so like he went there and they're like
go away alex get out of here alex and
like literally they start going like
yeah you know i'm glad your mom died and
[ __ ] like that like it was [ __ ]
like it was i actually heard you at one
point because they were like yeah well
you know that's why your mom's dead or
whatever blob i'm glad your mom's dead
and uh i heard you in the background
just go yeah well you know your dad's
dead to you so i mean you know
because we're even here i'm sorry right
there yeah yeah yeah so dude i was going
around with the megaphone and one of i
was at a rally yesterday too one of my
favorite things to do to antifa is like
when they're all standing somewhere i'm
like sit down if you know your father
and then of course none of them sit down
and they just look so stupid but
well still fun to mess with dude i mean
they're just they're just there to bully
i would say yeah and easy easy to do it
and then they play the victims and then
they'll dox you and your entire family
and then they'll get a gofundme and
it'll be fun
but that's just what that's just that's
that's just how it works but this is
great so this is you at a this is like
my favorite one he's ever done uh
houston city council
this one's so this is so passive
aggressive the entire time so anything
better than passive aggressive this
whole thing is it just is he's a master
class of passive aggression
it's it's so funny before we hit play
and i'm sure you'll come on this alice
i've talked to i've talked to it with
stein and also with cassidy campbell
even when you look at these city council
meetings look who the [ __ ] they think
they are like look at look at how nice
it is in there and they're they're
sitting above you and they're oh look at
me i'm a you know you're a bunch of
[ __ ] losers like everybody else you
know
they they really do think who they are
i like to call but i'll call the houston
mayor mayor limparist because he is the
most down low
mayor you'll ever see i mean just
listening to him it just makes your
gaydar go off and you know with him he
likes to cut me off you know literally
earlier in that council meeting he was
giving people 30 minutes that were
kissed like literally 30 minutes they
were kissing his ass like saying oh
you're doing such a good job with the
bike paths like you wanted to hear more
from them but you know he cut me off
early i think on this one he gave me
three minutes but i did one uh this past
tuesday he cut me off early so next time
i'm not even gonna troll i'm just gonna
have a list of his scandals and just
start reading them off to them and you
know and because i'm a tax paying
citizen and some of those bums in there
i bet you i probably pay more taxes than
they do so i mean i should be able to
speak for three minutes but my opening
line is going to be yeah mayor turner i
hope you don't cut me off in two minutes
this time i know it wouldn't be the
first time you finish off a guy in two
minutes and you know
i want to make an illusion that he's gay
on every single city council thing just
just keep just keep hitting the
same hilarious gay guy whatever dude i
actually before we have played too i
want to say i was watching
since you brought up taxpayer i was
watching another one of your videos
yesterday the one where you went to new
york and like the brother of the guy was
sleeping like in one of the rooms or
whatever and he's like so he just sleeps
all day like doesn't have a job and he's
like no and he's like yeah that's fine i
mean i'll just float his whole existence
forever i guess
i remember that
so uh this is him in the uh houston
only one person at the front okay
i'm with an organization actually
he'll hear me okay yeah cool cool
my name is alex rosen i work for
miracles for migrants we are an ngo
miracles for migrants
that's [ __ ] hilarious dude funded by
multiple credible organizations and
people
such as the world economic forum george
soros's open border society foundation
and with the removal of title 42 which
will end up opening up our border and
lead to an influx of undocumented
persons coming into this great country
we are going to have to take care of
them
mayor turner i know you've been one of
donald trump's staunchest attractors
declaring this place a sanctuary city
which gives amnesty and a haven to
undocumented citizens
lena hidalgo our county judge is also
sponsored by dream and endorsed by them
which is an organization for
undocumented children
here with me i have three undocumented
persons that came straight from the
border approximately on march 28th
since good leaders always step up to the
plate i want to ask you mayor judge and
council members if you'd like to take
them into your own homes because we all
we all talk a good game about you know
obviously taking care of them and having
tax money go to them but i'd like you
guys to try to take them into take them
into your own homes i have them with me
right here they're very great people
first i have juan from guatemala
no you cannot have them up front
this is great optics by the way because
they don't even want them within a
couple of feet they don't even want them
in that building like that was a
beautiful play because you're like come
on up come on pal and they're like no no
no you keep that filthy mexican away
from us you know what i mean and you're
like you're the one that brought him
you're like oh come on buddy we're all
pals here
yeah
you cannot bring them up front sir
he has a warrant for arson in guatemala
city but
he just got a little bit carried away
and we all make mistakes he's a great
reference
and that doesn't mean he doesn't deserve
a second chance he came into this
country to avoid prosecution and he's a
good soul just a little bit of a
misguided one he needs a home for the
next five years
in order to avoid prosecution and
potential death in guatemala do any of
the city city council members want to
take them into ntl's homes
anybody
going once going twice no okay
wow they [ __ ] hate you oh yeah oh
yeah
get ready get ready for his very passive
aggressive little wow weird
what's my favorite part of the video is
wow no nobody weird
your passive aggressions just [ __ ]
dude and i like the reference to your
poaching
in the video because he does that
all the time when he's interviewing
these predators where he's like it's
okay man look you just got a little
carried away everybody makes mistakes
right like well yeah he needs he needs
continuity like a marvel movie like it's
all connected story the way he does it
when he's interviewing the predators
he's just like look i'm not saying like
you're just into kids you're not like
some [ __ ] weirdo but i'm just saying
like nah right like any age like he gets
them to just admit this [ __ ] while
thinking like nah bro i'm not judging
you dude like he's even straight on gone
as far to say like bro i've been in this
evolved the same situation man all right
i got caught doing the same show i get
it bro i'm trying to help you i don't
want the cops
i guess a question i have for you
are you do you ever you ever worry that
one of these [ __ ] psycho's going to
like do something
well funny enough one of the guys we
confronted who was an attempted murderer
i just found out today
he was like still out he got indicted by
a grand jury for child porn and um i
think ah something with a minor under 16
i think it was probably because of our
decoy work and our tips to them
but he shot a cop today and there's
definitely been some people whoa
whoa whoa really
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah you literally dodged
a bullet on that one yeah i really
dodged a bullet yes dude and
yeah then tomorrow we're probably we're
set to confront somebody that's a you
know convicted convicted killer he you
know he got charged with manslaughter
but he was taken down for murder but i
think it was a fatal uh fatal driving
accident and he's also a sex offender so
he definitely come across them
potentially dangerous people for sure
you know and i've i've thought about
that too as far as
because like if i were in your position
i would i would be like well i'm not
going anywhere i always carry anyway i
just always i have concealed carry here
so i always bring it with me anywhere um
but you're in a kind of a like odd spot
right because you're going to them
to confront them on this stuff
so it's like even if they pull a gun and
you shoot them it's on their property or
at their job so it's kind of
it kind of puts you in a weird position
because i don't even think technically
you could carry if you wanted to right
because you would
shoot somebody at their own [ __ ] home
then
yeah you know what i mean it's not
really going to help
yeah no it's pretty risky what we do i i
will say um
basically being being a bullshitter and
being a slick talker to them goes a very
long way and
you do yeah you're you're great you're
young how old are you again
22. jesus christ dude you have such a
high upside now you're so you're young
man you really
you know
damn just be careful that's all i said
and i don't mean by the way i'm not
talking about be careful when you go out
here to confront these people because
you could handle yourself but be careful
that these other [ __ ] vultures don't
try to get their hooks in you and be
like oh yeah you're on our side now
you'd be just you know
yeah try try to stay
you know independent yeah yeah
yeah the last thing you want is to be
talking next to lady mag at a tp usa
just being like hey young americans
foundation let's go
guys as you know the number the number
one way to grow the conservative
movement is just becoming liberals
honestly right i mean that's pretty much
what it is now yes obviously it is and i
think i think that maybe your channel
will do a lot better on youtube if you
did it in address my friend you know
what no you know what none of those
people can ever answer and it's a simple
question
what are you conserving
yeah and they can never answer that
question it's always well look we've got
to build the base
yeah i like look i like butt sex just as
much as a liberal candidate but look
your tax will be two percent lower under
pay that's pretty much the conservative
platform nowadays that's all it is it
really is slightly lower taxes but sorry
your kids are still going to get
molested in school
yeah we had we had to give up something
for those low taxes no but then even
that doesn't work because they're not
conserving [ __ ] either because they're
like look the spending bill was going to
be three trillion dollars we knocked
that bad boy down to 2.9 trillion oh
thanks
oh we're all safe now i'll never forget
dave reilly go into that [ __ ] uh what
was the turning point usa thing into
college dead ass asking rob smith to his
face and charlie kirk how does anal sex
help us win the culture war
and they just were like
you know what i mean and it's like it's
like you know what i mean it used to be
young guys in suits like little remember
alex p keaton yeah yeah yeah bro [ __ ]
he doesn't though he's too young he
doesn't get that reference
uh
so what are you on the road are you
doing uh you think you're gonna have to
give up uh you know the details but are
you uh
are you uh i'm actually i'm actually at
cass today's house right now but his
editor's on the computer um editing a
clip we did so i'm just on my phone in
the car
so what is dude it's it's amazing
between you cassidy campbell and alex
stein you guys are
absolutely exhaustingly prolific like
you guys work all the time it's pretty
insane to me like we're pretty lazy yeah
we don't understand what you guys do
because it's between you being on the
road chasing these dudes all the time
and then i'm [ __ ]
you know you guys going to the town hall
meetings and now alex is going over to
blaze and cassidy's constantly on the
[ __ ] like a grind like it's
do you guys ever just like i don't know
turn it off
relax a little bit
because the way i look at it is you know
this is pretty much a vacation to me i
mean i've you know in part because of me
and park is a luck you know i've been
blessed enough to where having fun is my
job and doing something good for society
is my job so you know
a day where i'm not doing anything you
know i feel like
i just don't feel accomplished like not
saying i feel like depressed or anything
but i just don't feel accomplished i
just feel like it's a wasted day
and you know it's not fun it's funner
for me to work than it is to relax and
you know i'm glad i have that mentality
because it leads to what seems to be
good things
yeah you must enjoy road trips man
because you're always on the [ __ ]
road
yeah dude yeah you're you're running
around a lot
yeah well it also makes my wardrobe half
food challenges
half of food challenge shirts because i
mean like this is a food challenge right
here i mean you know what keeps me going
is like i just look up like famous
places in the area and i always go eat
there and it you know makes me look like
this oh my god i have an idea you should
if you're doing it anyway make a little
extra money start a side channel you
know
yeah called like food poachers where you
go out there you do food challenges i
mean that would be [ __ ] great uh yeah
i should man i should people have told
me to go start one i don't know why i
haven't yet i always live stream the
food challenges but
plus that's a great way to build up a
channel in case you get zapped again
because the algorithm will love you and
it'll let you
pretty much it'll just carry you up in
the algorithm because they love those
food challenge videos and then you'll
just have a channel lined up ready
monetized in case they pop because i
know they do pop you you know they've
they've gotten you a couple times
because we talked about it in dallas
you've lost some pretty large channels
oh it's a pain in the ass man it's a
huge pain are you ever worried they're
going to do like make this sort of thing
illegal you know because like they you
know again they only want the media the
mainstream media to be allowed to do
news and do right stuff like that
and i know like to catch a predator was
like kind of the main one but do you
think that there's gonna come a day
where
they somehow because i i seem to notice
a trend of those in power
um that seem to really enjoy banging
kids so i feel like eventually they're
gonna wanna
maybe curtail your your behavior a bit
yeah i mean i think about that sometimes
but it's at a point now where there's a
lot more there's a lot more awareness
for this going on now like a lot of
local news stations are covering like
not just my bus but people's bus all
over the country
so there's a growing awareness for this
movement and you know of course we're
working against the normalization of
pedophilia but right now i think i think
it's kind of in a gridlock because i
think the outrage would be too much
right now and pedophilia isn't
normalized enough yet for them to just
you know make it all good make make all
this stuff go away without there being a
pushback but um you know i kind of think
of it as like you know if one kid
screams in a first grade class the whole
class doesn't go to recess and you know
that's how it could be with these
channels um
you know if one channel say
you know pushes someone to the edge and
they committed suicide on camera you
know i hope it doesn't happen to us or
really anybody but then then that could
give youtube an excuse to say hey you
know this happened so now we can't do
this or if like a channel like you know
bully someone like out of you know just
berates them and berates them berates
them you know it could ruin it for
everybody else so we have to be very
careful make sure that everybody's on
the same page doing it they're doing it
the quote-unquote right way like in the
in the boundary law oh don't worry
something i've learned here is someone
will ruin it
i mean it's unfortunate but that's just
the same thing with like irl streaming
yeah when that first started like you
know the cx and then like ip2 and all
that stuff like those people i remember
being like
somebody's going to [ __ ] this up someday
like somebody's going to do the wrong
and now you have andy dick sexually
harassing people on an rv not only
sexually harassing but actually fondling
and groping yeah this is a [ __ ] weird
dude yeah he's pretty gross really he's
a weird guy huh
uh so what's like the worst dude that
you've ever come across like
like like someone that made you go like
jesus christ like one of those things
that made you just totally black built
for the rest of the day yeah
oh definitely youtube guys you guys just
depressed me just watching
okay that was that was amazing
fair enough you're [ __ ] great thank
you yeah
no there's there's no
you know when i come across somebody bad
um
it's not it's not a black pill for me at
all it's it's more of a
you know it's more it's more of a white
pill because you know we can get these
people that have been under the radar
for decades that go that don't go found
out or anything like that and if we can
expose them that means anybody can
because we're just we're just 22 year
olds with a camera so the worst people
we get yeah on one hand you know you're
you're shocked that this is in society
but on the other hand
you know like hey we can expose these
people and we can eventually we can put
a huge dent in this i mean child abuse
is never going to end sadly i mean it's
just way too prevalent um for everybody
to pick up on and and also lebron james
needs shoes so of course child abuse
isn't gonna end you know you gotta
exploit them somehow oh yeah yeah yeah
what do you want us to do make them here
yeah we're not gonna make it we have
childs the child uh slave stuff over
there that lebron james doesn't care
about apparently
right right i mean on one hand i mean
chinese eight-year-olds make way more
than the eight-year-olds here they're
already beating us for the next
generation
that's a good point and by the way they
by the time they hit the [ __ ] job
market they've had 20 years of
experience
because they've been making shoots since
they were seven years old
oh my god
so like honestly like how do you
keep your cool i guess would be my thing
because like you do i've watched a bunch
of these videos and you just man your
[ __ ] heart rate doesn't even go up
man like you're just
you're just very smooth about it you'll
you'll you don't overdo it with the
humor but you're always it's always
guaranteed every like 45 seconds or so
that he's gonna like pop off some
[ __ ] you know well he's left here
because of the food challenges so is
that what it is do you do the food
challenges before you go get these guys
how do you keep your cool and stay like
on focus so well without kind of your
blood boiling i guess
well um
you know i definitely don't want to go
to jail and i know i'm the quote-unquote
aggressor in these situations
yeah i mean you know the threat of jail
is just you know horrible because i was
in jail for only six hours and six hours
was like six times too much for me so i
was just forget that
but
for this
oh no no no not for that oh okay
yeah something else but it was like uh
you know the way the way i look at it is
you know i don't really imagine what
said in the messages i just say i just
try to get them to admit to wanting to
do what was in the messages and you know
i just look at it more as i just got to
beat the guy in front of me and
oftentimes we do
and you know i can be mad at them after
or something i can celebrate and mock
them when they're in cuffs
right i have see i will say i have seen
him lose his temper one time
was uh you did one in houston i think
and it was uh some guy that was like
using religion as a cover the whole time
and he was turns out he was just some
meth guy that was like
showing up to a walmart to [ __ ] some kid
and he just kept using bible bible this
bible that i was here to i was actually
going to just meet a lot of them always
say oh i was just meeting them to
tell them not to meet grown men on the
it's like a very convoluted excuse but
then somebody started revving their
truck in the background while you're on
the phone with his dad and you
i could just see it was
there was one time i saw his [ __ ]
temperature kept going up and then he
[ __ ] screwed and it's bleeped out on
the regular free versions because he has
to keep the chat but you
unloaded a tirade of expletives at that
truck
and then went back to talking on the
phone and then you yelled at the guy's
girlfriend and you were like you really
have like bad self-esteem and you need
to stop dating this guy and like just
let him rot in jail like you shouldn't
be doing this to yourself you're better
than this and blah blah blah and then uh
later like at the end you were talking
to his dad and you were like well i mean
i don't know man your son's a pedophile
i don't tell you bro but uh you know
he's probably not gonna get locked up
because this [ __ ] mayor he just lets
any [ __ ] thing happen in this [ __ ]
city and you were just screaming in a
parking lot and i was like man he hates
houston
oh i do it is it is such a crap hole
dude um
you see just seeing crime go up and
especially in my apartments too there's
like a siren almost every night and you
hear you you do hear gunshots and you
know it's
it's bad it's it's bad there's nothing
we don't bring in chicago pizza in
houston only chicago crime and it's very
messed up well you guys also got um
an influx of people after katrina that
didn't exactly oh that's true um
help houston uh as far as growing and
becoming more stable i remember that a
bunch of people just went straight from
louisiana to houston
and uh they were like i guess i'm here
now
yeah no one of my best friends um he is
you know he came because of katrina but
yeah katrina definitely you know it
definitely made houston a lot more
crime-ridden for sure and it doesn't
help that lena hidalgo our county judge
is signing signing executive orders to
give 50 bails to people that beat the
crap out of their grandmothers and also
um i had a high school teammate who just
went to jail for brother like a week or
two ago and he was out on three felony
he was out on three felonies on only a
hundred dollar bill i mean it's it's
horrible here it's pretty much like the
wild west and it is crappy be armed at
least you don't have an open border in
texas so you guys will be fine right
yeah no our governor has been on sean
hannity multiple times and assured us
that he is in fact building the border
yeah yeah well yeah that guy uh that guy
uh doesn't stand for anything really um
no he's spineless he's spotless he
really is yeah he's true no but yeah i
just like the fact that your governor
copies our governor's homework yeah
that's right that's actually true every
time desantis says something like three
minutes it comes out like no that's not
a bad idea we're ending the lockdowns
too and it's like you know cause
he doesn't take his stance on anything
i don't know because it's a ramp you
know maybe unless with those wheelchairs
that you lift yeah i mean maybe he'll
ramp up border security
not knowing him he'll just make it
handicap accessible so the ones in
wheelchairs the ones in wheelchairs can
get across
look we're not doing enough for the
handicapped migrants guys
true man
that's so true
come across like that no man it's it's
but but it's it's bad like it's like now
he's finally going like oh yeah we're
gonna send some people to the border i'm
like you've been saying that for a while
and by the way abbott busting 30 illegal
immigrants to dc's not gonna do anything
they're gonna ship them off to swing
states that's a [ __ ] good point
you're right they're gonna come they'll
you're right they're gonna go back to
pennsylvania or stuff like that places
yeah
i will say under greg abbott the mexican
food has gotten ten times better under
him which is weird somebody's doing
border security that's really that's
really good you know your border you you
know you live in a safe town where the
mexican food's bad i'm not gonna lie man
royce picked out the dumpiest looking
taqueria that i've ever seen in my life
it's so good but it was like
you knew it was gonna be good because it
looked like a dump but the only people
going in and out were mexicans to eat
and royce is like we're going to that
one and it was the best tacos i've ever
had in my lifetime it was like it's some
[ __ ] in dallas somewhere and no
wasn't that was it was between dallas
and arlington because i think it was
between dallas and arlington right right
but oh dude i would say i mean
you know as long as they're going to
take our jobs i'm cool with like nine
dollar four i'm cool like four inch a
lot for nine dollars in a flank steak on
top of it at a grocery store that's you
know
that's that's a that's really good but
you know we talk about it on the show
and it's like it's even shifted too
because the big illegal limiting thing
that we talked about years ago was you
know oh there's a lot of mexicans coming
in this country that's not even what's
coming across the border anymore right
right like you know that's fentanyl and
terrorists right right so so that's the
point the point is like people you just
say mexicans are not really like for the
most part you know i obviously believe
they should come here legally but for
the most part mexicans are hard workers
they go to work every day and they
they're very
socially at least they're very
conservative right they're very family
yeah honestly give me a mexican give me
a mexican over a whitey any day whitey's
are just effeminate masculine now i mean
honestly they are they're they're not
like you know and they're all
they're all like neocons now i mean dude
mexicans are usually better but oh they
are looking because because that's the
thing like they come over they're
catholic they just want to go to work
and that's and by the way they tried to
pull that gender [ __ ] on them and they
go latinx yeah we're not calling
ourselves that go [ __ ] yourself and then
we're not doing it but what's coming
across the border now isn't that what's
coming across the mortars like you know
a border now is like from even poorer i
know and people think mexico is poor
there are poorer countries in mexico you
know that like you said they're coming
home
guatemala haiti a lot of coming from
haiti and and and then you know it's
people coming across and it's like it's
the better their life but it's not
anymore it's to get free school
you know to to get to get a phone now
we're giving them phones and they go
we're giving them phone so we could
track them first off are you tracking me
on my phone and secondly we're just
we're giving them iphones like
it's it's it's bad and i mean
we're since florida is is is you know
we're surrounded by water we don't
really have a huge illegal immigrant
problem like you know sometimes a cuban
will show up on a raft or something but
it's not like that but for you guys it
has to be like every day right and
you're in houston which isn't even a
border town but even still i've heard
people that live there live in austin
live and even dallas so like it's
getting really bad
yeah my friend um he did say on a street
right by like our house
uh
there was just a i think it was the
vanderbilt i'm not sure but there was a
vehicle and then just a bunch of
hispanics just rolled out of there just
like they just all scattered out of
there i mean it is it's a very real
thing and greg abbott knows a hundred
percent about it
oh yeah of course by the way
you did comment about them taking our
jobs i think our jobs are secure and i
think yours will be fine but i i think
other jobs will probably i don't i don't
can't see a guy in a really thick
mexican accent doing what alex does
unless he's going after a certain
demographic that actually would be funny
though you stay here you want to eat
[Laughter]
and then he shows up he shows up to
every poaching a low rider yeah like
just
hydraulics and he just steals your logo
but he just does the uh upside down
exclamation point
let me rap with you real quick come over
to my car
hey by the way um you know we talked
briefly about your uh issue with uh
getting taken down i guess from shopify
which is pretty [ __ ] up by the way um
i don't even know what it was what what
is it that um
like how
listen two questions one when are you
gonna get merch out again because i need
one of them gordon flower shirts
two
is it only sweatshirts because some of
us here in florida you know we need a
t-shirt we wear sweatshirts like two two
nights out of the year
yes uh we do have t-shirts and we did
make our own website so actually um i
was gonna probably get that out there in
the next few days like on the next video
start plugging it but
yeah i got the website up so i will be
uh giving that to you guys yeah cause i
definitely want to get my hands on one
of them t i want a t-shirt though yeah
man cause that's uh that's a [ __ ] i
died i told him that like from day one
i'm like i gotta get my hand when i'm
gordon flower [ __ ] i need that in my
[ __ ] in my drip
and your trip don't say drip drip don't
say drip
it's not hey you can say whatever you
want man you could say drip if you want
to no word belongs to any one race you
know you can say whatever word you want
oh oh i'm pretty sure on youtube that
there's a word that belongs to race that
i cannot say sir i am a hundred i am a
hundred percent positive i could say
[ __ ] because i'm a [ __ ] i could call
myself a [ __ ] as long as i'm calling my
cell phone and by the way yeah i could
call them a [ __ ] too i like hey
wait a second no
by the way i'm giving you i'm giving you
a spit pass because i'm i like you and
i'm giving you one you have one if you
ever get in trouble you say royce lopez
said i'm allowed
wait hold on my fbi agent's calling me
oh great i
tried to get him to say the word you
know
no it looks like they're still gonna be
up for a little bit
i'll get him next time he's he's baiting
us oh god no and by the way i've seen
the cr the crew that alex rolls with you
didn't need to give him that pass yeah
he rolls he rolls with a bunch of
[ __ ] mexican dudes okay well i wanted
to say it publicly on a show some people
know instead of instead of the spice
girls we're the [ __ ] boys that's that's
worse i like
i do i do like that who are you are you
scared are you scary [ __ ]
or sporty [ __ ] dude
i liked the uh he did one one time up in
new york where he caught some guy who
was like autistic and jewish and smoked
crack i was one of my friends you could
have just said new yorker and uh
he got he actually called the guy's dad
on the guy's cell phone and was talking
oh i saw that one and he was like yeah
you gotta be careful man your son gets
caught man so he's gonna cut off his
matzo balls and they were like
oh that's very anti-semitic and you were
like yeah i'm jewish [ __ ] face i have a
pass i wanted to make whatever joke i
want i was dying laughing
oh my god rabinowitz dude that is the
mush that was the jewiest shoe i've ever
come across that guy was so uh the thing
what my favorite part of that video was
he goes uh i smoke crack and you're like
wait you smoke crack like and you're
like where do you get your crack and he
goes i'm not gonna give out that
information
okay his name's michael lafrancois and
actually right now he has two bench
warrants out currently because then he
crashed my car last year like you didn't
even press him any further he just said
i'm not giving that out there was a
maybe a millisecond of silence a little
pause and he goes okay his name's
michael officer yeah i know jesus man oh
[ __ ] man dude i saw your you're all
you're always i mean i give you credit
man you are you are always [ __ ]
working and that's great you know um i
mean i really do hope that does youtube
so have you monetized her now
um you know as of now we're okay
okay i mean as of now we'll pray for you
i mean that's what we could do on our
end
that's about it
you know we haven't been we have how
many times have we reapplied to get our
money i apply ever i've been applying
every six months for three years
just in case
yeah and they just and they just stole
three grand from us
not us they also just stole thirty three
hundred from they sold thirty three
hundred dollars they never mind
yeah they're really nice this is a nice
platform i love it it's great susan
doesn't like us too much one time we got
a strike for bullying uh dead jeffrey
epstein that's not a lie that's for real
yeah oh yeah you all told me that yeah
we got we got the jeffrey epstein one we
got popped for i think one of the dan
schneider videos
remember we were oh yeah yeah we were
bullying poor dan schneider of
nickelodeon because
uh we were covering now what five years
ago like we were very early to the dan
schneider nickelodeon party and uh not
earlier than britney spears's sister
oh that kid looks nothing like him um
but yeah that was what who's the dad
then
no um i don't know that's not some guy
that they found to come out and be the
dad yeah but yeah we were covering that
and like they'll go back and roll back
and hit like a five-year-old episode for
bullying yeah that's the problem so the
problem is like alex that's what you
have to worry about is like you have all
these videos and they're great but if
one day they decide to change the rules
they'll pop you for something that used
to be okay that's not anymore yeah you
gotta stop bullying these poor kid
diddlers yeah i try to be very very
careful now like i just uh
like yeah i don't as you as you'll see i
don't raise my voice on them and any
jokes i do tell are like in like a
monotone accents are like monotone it's
sarcastic so you know the bots don't
pick up on it because dude it is
it's it's really bad here it's it stinks
by the way can i say something too
welcome to the bald head beard society
isn't it great
isn't it great
yeah you know my hair's gonna be back in
like a week but yeah it's good to be
here for a little bit it's nice
it's nice i like it yeah i'm fighting my
baldness right now and he's losing i am
losing but um you know i'm already using
topical solutions and [ __ ] i'm like i
just want like another year or two of
hair before i joined the bald head beard
club i started balding when i was 23 i
think so it was bad for me but who gives
a [ __ ] you should you should uh merge
you should call your podcast the joe
rogaine experience then the joe rogaine
experience so joe rogaine experience is
really good i know i'll just get hair
updates right yeah i'll just turn my
show completely into updates about my
cat and my hair and then start shielding
like on it hair products
by the way going back to another funny
thing he actually was watching one of
his last night of the little mexican
dude at sonic he literally called him
george really lopez
[ __ ] that's really good man really fun
anyways a lot of these guys that he
catches are like not let's just say
they're not the
they're not sending their best like
they're usually not very high iq so they
don't pick up on a lot of it which is
even funnier right because they're like
what and you're like oh no man i'm sorry
i was confused something else anyway he
just got plowing right into it but yeah
he doesn't really like raise his voice
and i will say you do
tell a very good line i see that
uh some people
uh might get a little frustrated because
they'd rather see these people just
beating up and it's like but no he's
getting he's getting them caught by
which is better like
you pretend to understand them and
like you're just nice to them and it's
like it's weird man you really just mind
[ __ ] these dudes and by the end of it
it's like
they just give it all up it's insane
but dude
it is actually it is great because you
know a lot of the times
a lot of the black pills and of course
we're part of that but is like oh man
these younger dudes are not going to be
as as based as we are then you see
people like you and you know younger
dudes doing you're like okay so there's
still some yeah i mean
we went out to dinner in dallas there's
a whole table of based people no yeah by
the way can we bring that up real quick
a whole table of base people who just
finished trolling so i'm sitting next to
a dude in a hillary shirt hey [ __ ] it
you got a bite in 2020 shirt and i'm
like oh god damn it they're gonna think
we're [ __ ] yeah they were uh yeah we
were that was so funny we definitely
stood out in that place but it's it's
nice to see
young guys who obviously have way more
energy than we do uh and more talented
going in honestly
going out and taking it to him yeah
well dude the thing is it's it's an
uphill battle with my generation for
sure because the thing is most people in
the generation they can they can be
swayed one way or another i'm setting my
beliefs but the thing is there's more
people setting their beliefs i would say
on the left and the thing is about the
left they're way more passionate than we
are like there's nobody there's nobody
like me alex and cats there's really
that's no there's only
there's three of us
and you know like what i want to do with
these city councils you know i want to
get other people to say hey it's okay to
make fun of these people because i know
we're all thinking these people are
corrupt and they're scumbags and that
the you know pronouns are [ __ ]
and you know i want them to have the
courage to be able to speak out against
this stuff too because a lot of it a lot
of it is a lot of a lot of people do
think um
these radical lefties are insane but
they're just so afraid to speak out and
that's what i want to do like i want to
say hey it's okay to go to an antifa
reality start berating them because
they're pos man you know you're not the
only one that thinks they're insane but
they're so scared to speaking out
because what what the left is so good at
especially with antivirus like even in
person they're so good at sticking
together and doing the strength and
numbers thing because even then i was
trying to get one of them uh yeah i
haven't uploaded it yet but i was trying
to get one of them in the crowd to like
you know try to bait them out so i could
take off rip off his mask but
you know because they're already pushing
us and like you know trying to shove us
and you know hit our stuff so i was like
all right well i'm gonna try to identify
one of these people and you know they're
so good at sticking together and you
know they're good at making a bunch of
little things to combine into one big
monster and that's what everybody's
afraid of but they've got to realize as
individuals these people are cowards and
they don't want to they're so scared of
their true beliefs that they don't even
want to show their face i mean they are
just disgusting people and it's okay to
speak out against that well it's it's
funny and i'll say this i i will say
that i our generation i want to
apologize for antifa because we didn't
bully them enough when they were younger
yeah that's our fault we should have
stuck him in more lockers but we were
taught bullying was bad we were talking
about so we didn't we didn't do it we
didn't do anything about it we could
have we should have kept the [ __ ] out of
these we could have stopped this could
have been over if they would have been
punched in high school they wouldn't be
doing this now i mean that like a lot of
these people you go oh you ever see i'm
sure you see all the time out the other
time you go oh you just never been
punched you're like oh i get it you're
like this because no one's ever punched
you in the mouth you know
and and and it's a life-changing
experience right and i'm not saying that
you should go around hitting people i
don't believe that that's the anti-fall
stupid but everyone should get one your
you know you say the wrong thing to the
wrong kid at school and he pops you one
and you're like oh okay so i'm gonna get
hit if i'm a complete prick all the time
so i either need to shut up or learn how
to hit back really well and then it's
you know you got to learn one of the two
but they swarm you like a [ __ ] like
they swarm they swarm you like a zerg
rush and there's really nothing you
could do because kyle rittenhouse can't
be everywhere yeah right now every every
one time he's one man he's one man
that's funny i'll bring that up man like
after after like the stream yesterday
you know when i was streaming you know
confronting like it was five on 40. um
yeah my girlfriend said the same thing
like hey yeah you know we got to bring
bullying back saying she said the same
damn thing and we do man because you
know and then we also live in a place
where mental health is so glorified like
the more you talk about how your
problems are quote-unquote okay the more
they're complacent in their problems
like they're like oh it's okay because
it's so scared to be judged but then
when somebody's like oh you know what
it's okay to it's okay to just be
mediocre it's okay to just be depressed
all the time and they're gonna they're
not gonna think they have to be any
better but when everybody tells them hey
get your ass up and go then people are
gonna be more motivated more motivated
to do it man it's been a it's been a
brainwashing for generations well no you
i mean
100
and um i i do think that
i at least a little bit people have
started to realize enough with this [ __ ]
you know and honestly if we're going to
blame somebody for the mental health
stuff that's not we that's not our
merchandise generation that's the
boomers that was reagan who got rid of
[ __ ] nut huts because we did used to
have a place for people and we didn't
glorify it and we didn't say oh oh i'm
so oh susan it's okay that you're it's
okay that you're a [ __ ] you're bipolar
because a lot of these people hide their
shittiness behind their mental health it
happens all the time right it's like i'm
allowed to be a prick because i'm poor
i'm borderline you know you're like no
no i'm sorry you're borderline but you
don't get to be a dick because of it you
know thank you ronald reagan your legacy
is attacked
oh my god he is the best president ever
yeah i got to go back to your other
point too that you were making about
like you know the one thing about going
up and berating these people um i gotta
say i think what makes you you know you
cassidy alkstein and kind of you know uh
to a lesser extent what we do over here
um the
humor is what works i think the most as
far as swaying people i mean i think i
think you guys managing to be funny were
like it's hard to get people to just
like first of all debates are stupid and
gay people that are constantly like
debate me destiny debate me nick fuentes
like i'm tired of listening to debates
debates are boring and stupid and but
but like comedy is what works man and
it's like whether you're growing a
channel catching predators like you got
funny and that's what you know people
are showing up to see is like you know
or they're showing up to see these guys
get caught but then they're staying it's
like this guy's pretty [ __ ] funny
yeah or when you're doing the town hall
stuff like you know with the mexican
guys like it's the being funny i think
is the most powerful thing you can do
because then people are laughing but
then they're like wait wait a minute
though is that a real thing wait did you
did what is the world economic forum
like wait open borders what is that you
know what i mean or one of my favorite
ones with the young bucks with these
young bucks and we were [ __ ] eating
we were like yeah you've seen glenn beck
crying right and cnn and apologizing for
trump like wait what i'm like oh yeah he
totally did that yeah and it's memory
hole everything yeah they do memory home
of you they make everything disappear
right because you don't you know you you
did dan crenshaw like you go down the
list of people nobody wants
what he's doing now is good like what
mccarthy's [ __ ] doing now he was
caught on tape telling liz cheating yeah
i was trying to get rid of trump can we
get rid of the now he's like no i'm a
conservative and going back to the
beginning of the of this interview what
are you conserving what are you doing
you just left
you're you're the you're the left light
you know it's the same [ __ ] yeah
absolutely man and i yeah i think humor
is the best way being sarcastic mocking
people because it does bring curiosity
like during the summer of 11 20 20
there was this lady on like a
blm hotline that i prank called for
months like as a guy named jamal just
talking about how evil white people were
and you know there's been there's been a
bunch of people that have like come to
me said hey you know i used to be a
liberal and i started watching your live
streams and i've really changed my mind
and you know because i'll get her to say
the most ridiculous things like hey man
colton so don't you think like buildings
for the white people should just be like
destroyed and she's like oh yes
and it really put into perspective like
hey these people are nut cases and it
exposed that hard
uh i damned yes flew by we just did an
hour dude alex that was a lot of fun man
yeah an hour already yeah it's been an
hour i just looked at the clock and go
[ __ ] it it's been an hour dude when you
come down here let us know but we got to
do something that that'll be
a lot of fun if you ever make it down
yeah man you're uh you're a cool guy uh
had a lot of a lot of fun last time um
what how could people find you you said
the website's up now so or are you not
oh well that's like the merch website
but uh yeah i'll just plug that in the
videos but uh i mean i've been plugging
your channel in the chat and everything
but just so you people can find you
yeah um if you want to follow i mean you
know these are just channels that i like
myself that may or may not have me on
them like catching people so um your boy
jdq on youtube um predator poachers
southeast texas on youtube um gordon
flowers on youtube and puggy pug on
youtube where city council is nice and i
would say sub to all those channels they
have very good videos on there and my
twitter is football underscore 56 ol
that is football underscore 56 ol
and my instagram is f-i-d-d-y x-i-t-56
now did you play offensive line is that
what the ol is
uh yes i made that account in high
school because you know our coaches had
us make accounts and get film out to
like college coaches right of course
yes they still have that same thing
dude hey man thank you so much for being
on man we got to have you on again
you're always welcome yeah man thanks
for coming on like i said big fan and uh
it's you know pleasure to meet you in
dallas and uh you know just keep keep
doing it man keep all three of you just
keep doing what you're doing man yeah
that's so on target the three horsemen
of the of the city council apocalypse
[Laughter]
all right buddy thank you thank you guys
so much all right man take it easy take
care man
all right that was good man i flew the
[ __ ] by love you i should have said love
you [ __ ] i almost made it but it's
almost a perfect interview and i did the
i love you at the end again you got to
stop doing that man i know it makes the
guest uncomfortable no [ __ ]
that was fun man but yeah alex dunn your
boy jdq is the main channel if you want
to catch his stuff i'm posting the uh
puggy pug
um
one as well so but yeah i told you he
was based and funny man that's dude when
we went to dallas and [ __ ] alex was
like yo i know him i was like bro can
you please bring him out here i meet
this guy he's [ __ ] love his [ __ ] so
yeah thanks tim for coming on